la CPI Cour Pénale international a émis
ce 17 mars un mandat d'arrêt
international contre Vladimir Poutine le
président russe est accusé de crimes de
guerre pour la déportation d'enfants
Ukrainiens volody mirzuelinski a salué
une décision historique la Russie a
dénoncé un mandat d'arrêt juridiquement
insignifiant alors Vladimir Poutine
sera-t-il jugé par la CPI si oui quand
aura lieu ce jugement
déjà un peu d'histoire le Statut de Rome
un traité international a été créé en
2002 pour juger les pires crimes commis
dans le monde crime contre l'humanité
crime de guerre crimes d'agression et
génocide depuis sa fondation c'est la
première fois qu'elle vise un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies c'est une décision
historique parce que d'abord parce que
c'est les présidents qui ont été
inculpés sont assez rares il y en a eu
il y a eu Bechir il y a des filles cette
première en africain voilà la Russie
c'est un autre notre notre capacité et
ça démontre aussi que enfin dans
l'esprit j'imagine de dire que on ne
peut plus aujourd'hui
faire des guerres de ce type là
commettre les meurtres les atrocités des
crimes de guerre qu'on commet sans avoir
le payer mais de quoi est précisément
accusé Vladimir Poutine selon Kiev plus
de 16000 enfants ukrainiens ont été
déportés vers la Russie depuis
l'invasion le 24 février 2022 beaucoup
avait été placé dans des institutions et
des foyers d'accueil un mois après
l'émission de ce mandat d'arrêt le chef
du Kremlin n'a toujours pas été
interpellé voyons pourquoi tout d'abord
la cour pénal internationale ne juge pas
les accusés en leur absence et en plus
elle ne possède pas de force de police
capable de les interpeller mais alors
comment est-ce que le président russe
pourrait être arrêté les 123 pays partis
au Statut de Rome soit ceux qui
reconnaissent la CPI sont tenus
d'exécuter les mandats d'arrêt
c'est-à-dire que si Vladimir Poutine se
rend dans l'un de ses territoires le
pays en question se doit de
l'interpeller sauf que la CPI ne les
sanctionne pas en cas de non-implication
donc dans les faits cette obligation
n'est pas toujours respectée un état il
reste souverain et par exemple on a vu
avec El Bachir qui que lorsqu'il a été
mis en accusation pour génocide il est
actuellement mis en accusation par la
Cour pénale internationale pour génocide
il s'est rendu en Afrique du Sud
l'Afrique du Sud Est signalèrent de la
Cour pénale internationale et il y a eu
énormément de réactions mondiales et en
Afrique du Sud il a dû quitter le pays
précipitamment mais des des institutions
sud-africaines ne l'ont pas arrêté alors
qu'en réalité elles auraient dû le faire
d'ailleurs la Hongrie a déjà annoncé
qu'elle ne livre pas le président russe
à la cour pénal internationale si
l'entrée sur son territoire pourtant ce
pays a bien signé le Statut de Rome ce
qui devrait pousser Victor urbanne à le
faire autre scénario possible celui d'un
changement de régime à la tête de la
Russie aujourd'hui on imagine mal
Vladimir Poutine se faire arrêter alors
qu'il est Président dans son propre pays
on a dans ce sens un exemple assez
intéressant qui est celui de Slobodan ni
levitch devant le Tribunal pénal
international pour lexuslavie ou en fait
le bonheur milocevic il a été mis en
accusation pendant qu'il était chef
d'État on n'a pas pu l'arrêter et puis
un moment il a il a été en 2000 éjecté
de son poste de président à l'époque de
la Serbie enfin de l'ex ensuite de la
Serbie mais parce que il y a eu un
changement de régime et parce que à un
moment en fait les pays aussi ils se
rendent compte que par exemple ils vont
vouloir être soutenus par l'Union
européenne se tourner vers d'autres vers
d'autres organisations et qui savent
d'un point de vue politique qu'ils ont
ils vont devoir lâcher des choses le
président russe pourrait aussi ne jamais
comparaître devant la CPI c'est déjà le
cas de plusieurs personnalités
politiques Béchir non il n'a jamais été
il a jamais été arrêté par la CPI il est
arrêté par son propre pays et en prison
mais il n'a pas été déféré quand il est
renversé en 2019 à ce moment-là
effectivement il potentiellement des
bras mais les le gouvernement civil aux
militaire d'abord puis le gouvernement
qui ont mobilité ensuite
le coup d'État de 2021 ou pour l'instant
totalement refusé de le livrer autre
exemple Joseph Koni chef de l'Armée de
résistance du Seigneur est visée depuis
2005 par un mandat d'arrêt de la CPI
pour avoir lancé une rébellion sanglante
en Ouganda il n'a jamais été arrêté et
est toujours en fuite aujourd'hui
impossible donc de dire si Vladimir
Poutine sera jugé un jour ou pas je
pense qu'il faut pas qu'on dise que il
sera pas interpellé etc on n'en sait
rien vous savez moi j'ai travaillé en
Bosnie rat de comme l'a dit chez radoven
karadis qui était des têtes constantes
du nettoyage ethnique on a pensé pendant
des années qu'on les arrêterait pas
et puis finalement ils sont arrivés
devant le tribunal donc les choses elles
arrivent à un moment donc elles peuvent
arriver Vladimir Poutine il peut se
retrouver peut-être pas maintenant mais
dans je sais pas deux ans trois ans cinq
ans dix ans et je pense sincèrement qui
peut se retrouver devant la Cour pénale
internationale seulement je crois à
partir du moment où il y aura un
véritable changement au niveau interne
en Fédération de Russie si les
finalement interpellé reste à savoir si
le chef du Kremlin sera condamné parce
qu'être jugé devant la CPI ne garantit
pas une condamnation
cien président de la Côte d'Ivoire
Laurent Gbagbo celui du Kenya ou uru
kenyata ou encore l'ancien
vice-président de la RDC Jean-Pierre
Bamba ont tous les trois comparer devant
la CPI mais aucun n'a été jugé coupable
[Musique]